you see that big log right there yep
that's me wondering how the [__] I got
you that dude I'm interviewing just
finished boxing in the biggest event in
in in US history do you already knew
that right
I suppose this all started like many
stories dude with a woman nope not that
came in my grandmother it was the late
nineties and I was sat in her front room
watching my team hustle lose its second
Cup final in a row I knew I was never
gonna make it as a footballer so I would
just sit there toggle for everything
that happened this if I knew it all
anyway some things never change I think
everyone in the family was getting sick
of it to be honest with you
one day Graham Rogers Turner on it said
if you know so much why don't you go and
become a commentator and I thought I
might just do that no no I might just do
that but your childhood becomes your
teens and your teens wear you down
and next thing you know you're in high
school with a face full of spots trying
to cover up your hard-on with a long
coat [__] it was hard me teens days and
then everyone tries to put pressure on
you got a proper job or a career next
thing you know you're in a [__]
guidance counselor's room wondering what
the [__] you gonna do with yourself well
I decided again apprenticeship buick
engineering only lasted two years was a
fellow there who looked like Buddy Holly
as he is now though not in his prime
still lived the home with his mother 55
years old definitely still a virgin I
just didn't want to grow up to be that
guy so I went back to college while I
tried to work out what the [__] I wanted
to do with me like studied English
sociology psychology the English teacher
was mental he was a journalist for a
Newcastle football fanzine said I'd
never amount anything probably knows who
I am now at that point I was more lost
than I'd ever been all me me too I
started the apprenticeships with all
sticking in it there's and now finally
reaping the benefits and get money and I
still had fuck-all and then I seen this
video on YouTube and I thought I could
be youtuber but probably no money in it
but the video was of a deep-sea diver
and I knew there was money in that yep
I've actually managed to fit that into
another video amazing so you go to the
training centre get in the water realize
you don't know what the [__]
doing learn how to be a diver get a job
getting the water realize you don't know
what the [__] you're doing get better
work more get money get more money than
you've ever seen in your entire life go
home
go up drinks for all get girls more
girls and you've ever heard in your
entire life spend money all the money
back to work
dive back down come back like a little
dive back down for my death in the
family everything stops alcohol lots and
lots and lots of alcohol Demi friend
died who was a bigger Newcastle fun than
I've ever been depressed sod sick of it
and then in Newcastle player who didn't
really mean much to the club had a pop
of the funds and after George's funeral
I wasn't haven't knocked fires the
laptop up and let him know exactly what
I thought of him message to nail Ranger
here
I know people who [__] died who would
love to have been in your position
you're a [__] disgrace nail Ranger
you are a [__] disgrace 20,000 views
and one hour later just decided to leave
the video yeah I don't want that kind of
attention I don't want to be the crazy
football fan I like going to the shops
without anyone talking to me so deleted
it then I had a phone call of one of the
divers who said I was speaking what
everyone else was thinking and it had to
be reloaded I thought [__] it go on then
and then came more videos lots more
videos then I seen Joe Weller in chaos I
realised my videos were [__] but Spencer
us is the commentator on the Wembley
cough I thought wow I finally made it a
commentator at Wembley that was the
first big sporting event youtubers had
ever done and I loved commented after
the much ksi tweeted out that he thought
I killed it on commentary and after
watching it admiring his videos for a
while now that meant a lot like I'm
thinking if he believes that then maybe
I can't be good at this
so after a year of more videos I did the
Wembley Cup again and this time out of
fancy suit I really felt like I belonged
at that point and as I've been watching
Joe Rogan for
years I decided it was time to start the
podcast so I managed to get a few
minutes of YouTube on the podcast cuz
you know you got to get the numbers up
Joe well I came on and he told us how
ksi and held make his career good that
is actually the birth of my
opportunities those days where it all
began so obviously I could not be more
grateful here so I came on and told us
home Joe while I was the realest person
on YouTube
Joella is pretty much the same way if
guide is the most on the like the
realest person yeah it's weird how that
was all about a change so Joe decided
that he was gonna do a little boxing
video with this mate feel and he's done
music videos he turned wrestling videos
just another video he asked me to
commentate I'm holding an iPhone up to
my mouth while watching the footage of
him in his me in a gym punchin lumps out
of each other with zero boxing training
he uploads it ksi leaves a comment on
his Instagram saying I've got the winner
and it wasn't a serious comment but it
got very serious very quickly yeah well
you're taking a piss a depression 8,000
people see in your head absolutely crush
it adds up
[Applause]
and before I know it chaos is throwing a
security guard across the stage while
I'm holding our George Orwell offered to
our life it made for a hell of a picture
though so I went home to get ready to
comment it on the fight between the two
boys and then an American youtuber by
the name of Logan Paul would upload a
video that would impact a lot of people
including me and what happened in that
video brought back some dark memories
for me and I had to say something I
thought I'd be saying this on a video
but the kid is one in over forests in
Japan because it's known for suicides
finds a [__] dead body a little
[__] films everything fills the dead
body
[__] sick little [__] fruit it's
sad when someone feels I think there's
no other option oh that's the best
possible option this is death you know
at that moment I thought I'll never ever
meet this guy but at least I've said
what he needs to hear then it was time
to interview Jo and JJ before their big
fight when I interviewed Jo he was
saying all the right things I wasn't
sure what I believed that he could win
the fight and if it was was that because
he was saying all the right things or
was that just because I'm close up to
him and I don't want him to lose one
thing's for sure when I interviewed JJ I
knew he fully believed he was gonna win
this fight so much so he even told me to
remind him to call out the Logan Paul
guy I just made the video on after the
fight and after how angry I was at that
guy I wasn't gonna let JJ forget then we
got to the fight and even the way these
guys walked to the ring was like their
interviews jaws was kinda confident but
understated and not overly confident
whereas JJ's was just pure I am gonna
win this not a doubt in my mind when the
first Bell one jaw wasn't even thrown
punches and I knew with his confidence
being where it was he needed a good
start and that was not happening
I got to the point where I even pulled
the microphone away from my mouth to
shout at him you need the star thrown
punches it didn't work I really
struggled the commentator I fight this
was not like the Wembley Cup this was
watching one of your good friends take a
beating
in the ring and having to sound
impartial while telling people what's
happening and wincing every time your
meerkats punched in the face I didn't do
a good job I'm not used to being in
front of that many people and I was a
bit nervous even after the four glasses
of wine but I did remember that there
was one thing I needed to do you said
before this fight you had something
planned is there anything you want to
say to someone out you said you wanted
to call someone out tape or tape or
local porn and there's a port I don't
care I never thought that except JJ's
invitation but I've done my part so
Logan responds and he's clearly irate
that someone's called him out because he
is known as this guy who will never back
down to a challenge is the main man in
America and he's a night at me it's not
only did I make the first video or Smosh
and what he did in the suicide forest I
then also remained at JJ to call him out
so they caught me the white DJ coloured
JJ alb you're riding that white DJ
calendar thank you later cuz you owe him
one bro should be [__] busted I mean
like there's a beard in his shaven head
but that's where the similarities
beginning and I'm a good foot taller
than this guy and yeah I'm a better
music than him as well I reckon anyway
the beef is ignited and the road - ksi
versus log and pole begins
so before the fight they do the first
press conference in LA where Logan and
his brother Jake had clearly put some
money into this and they'd wanted to
level this show and instead of me they
had a former heavyweight champion of the
world I just felt like the whole thing
had left me behind despite my original
involvement like I was a nobody now you
know this is where it ends for me what
was clear about that press conference
was that JJ was no longer the big
brother in the beef like Logan was very
much his equal and the two eagles that
were colliding were on a par with one
another the world made a meme out of it
it went huge it did what it was supposed
to do everyone now knew these guys were
fighting so to my surprise they asked me
to do the London press conference after
I thought I was completely out the
picture
I definitely [__] it with what I said
about logging in the past I'm gonna do
it I'm at
we gonna get a do me dream job again
maybe Logan is not bad maybe he's
forgiven me for it maybe not when I seen
him he definitely knew who the [__] I
was and I knew I was gonna have to go
out there and ask this guy questions and
get something out of him so I just
looked at him sort of winked and said
let's have a good show so I walks out on
stage and I quickly realized that that
crowd is so loud I can't hear myself
think like I've never experienced
anything like that in the entire life
but not to worry once they hear me on
the microphone nil they're they'll quiet
and down problem is the microphones on a
podium that's about three foot from the
ground and there's no chair in front of
it so I'm stood up with a microphone
about three and a half foot away from my
face nobody can hear me talk that's a
problem I managed to get my hands on a
microphone and get a running order when
I'm onstage problem is start running
order is in the wrong order and people
aren't aware of the right order another
problem I managed to get to the core
main event which was dead G&G the
brothers of the main event and yeah Jake
just didn't seem to give a [__] about
the fan screaming I kind of appreciate
that for a minute
but quickly realized that it didn't
matter what I was thinking because
nobody was listening to me anyway yeah
dead she was shouting boring a lot over
when I was trying to talk you know on
Bruce Almighty when he sort of leans
back and closes his eyes and then a
asteroid hits the earth I'm kind of
hoping I could do that right at that
second JJ comes on stage and he goes in
on Logan and I'm thinking kind of
enjoying this but equally I didn't
revise for this for hours on end to not
ask any questions at some point I need
to step in
then again Logan was a dick in the past
and yeah I might just let this go a
little while longer definitely let that
go a little too long definitely before I
know it Logan's jacked it in and his
walking off the stage and I've lost
control completely [__] it so now I'm
thinking how the [__] can I make this
work out in my favor because that was a
[__] show I thought well how about I
just do a video explaining what was
going through my head the entire time so
that the audience can at least empathize
of where I'm coming from and also upon
ksi and Logan in the title I mean that's
not going to do me travel any harm is it
now in that video I definitely try to
psychoanalyze Logan especially after
he'd walked offstage I wanted to a come
up with an answer for that and be hope
that I hoped his ego just enough
thought he might respond to me and he
did I did the moderator let JJ talk for
five minutes and 20 seconds straight yes
I timed it and why are we not talking
about the fight and then I remembered
holy asshat this dude hates me cash back
I've never been happier for anyone to
say [__] about me in a video in my life
than when that video came out everyone's
texting me Logan Paul just went in on
you is if I should be devastated
I'm wringing Lawrence up i ringing all
the boys lads we've done it got the
million subscriber plaque we were they
were made we did it it was red party
night sure I mean it really was at that
point so our rings a Leo
I'm like me it come over we got some
work to do by the time he'd made up to
10-minute taxi ride to my house I had
written a few bullet points ready to
roll another BR open it's time to go in
on Logan Paul how am I supposed to
forgive Logan for what he did when he
can't forgive me for having a problem
with what he did who's the [__]
hypocrite I didn't just want to do what
all youtubers do which is paint
themselves out to be innocent and the
other person to be evil like I wanted to
accept where I had gone wrong but
disprove where I felt like he'd gone
wrong and then in that video I decided
like right there and then I'm gonna say
something that I've never said on
YouTube before that I found someone the
way in Logan found someone so that he
would know only him that's only for his
benefit I'm not outraged in that
original video for the sake of being
outraged for views like a lot of
youtubers do I'm outraged and hurt for
real reasons and if I do that and then
leave the door open in that video for
him and give him a second chance that
maybe he might take that and we might be
able to settle this and even be cool in
the future I wasn't holding out too much
hope but I left it at that anyway
shockingly Logan called we squashed it
and then I was hosting the fight it's
weird being on a call with someone who
you've publicly smashed and what's even
weirder is being cool with them and all
of a sudden realize and actually I could
shatter this guy's he's a dude who loved
sports the same way I do he's a cocky
guy who loves himself the same way I do
the difference is is he's just had a lot
of millions of people reaffirm that
belief in himself and at some point that
took over for him I could tell on the
phone he was making his way back to
being a grounded level-headed guy and
part of that was ringing New York mind a
man and I respected that and after that
call I was back call in the fight so
just like the last fight I decided I
wanted to do a podcast with both
fighters before their faults or could
release it the week of the fight when it
comes to the podcast with log and I did
thinking himself like potentially I
could just be like fuck'em I I've made
my name off the back of having a pop at
this guy now like I don't need to give
him the olive branch I know I could help
his image I know for a fact the podcast
with me and the way I could look after
him and bring the answers out of him the
best way possible I could help rebuild
his image I could have just said [__]
him why help him general I mean he's
done what he's done now but I kind of
felt like because he'd rang me up and
showed to me that there was a good
person in there somewhere that he was
worth the effort I've been working for
months on becoming a good podcaster and
now the pressure is really on and I'd
seen how other people that scrutinized
him and reduced him to a target and I
thought what if I do the same thing
they're gonna get the same results and
the previous results on other interviews
were who are like he's a 23 year old guy
when you attack him he shuts down you
know I mean he doesn't give you good
answers he just goes into defense mode
so me doing the same thing as everyone
else was never gonna work I had to think
of a way of getting the best out of him
and making him feel like he could talk
to me despite what I'd said in the past
when Logan came to my front door it was
a bit weird but we instantly hide it
like Luffy joke a warmth about it like
we we understand YouTube like people say
things sometimes people overreact and it
was all good but he had an entourage
with him and I was never gonna win him
over fully while he was around everyone
else so they went upstairs and he went
the toilet and I waited and just as he
come out I was like right let's go and
have a chat in my room and I explained
like I know people have attacked him in
the past and that's not what this is
about the only way we're gonna really
get anywhere is if we just talk this out
and I allowed him to have full editorial
control over the final upload which
means if there was anything in he wasn't
happy with they would remove it and I
would accept that and I never normally
do that but I knew the only way I was
gonna get him to relax as if he felt
like he was in control and when we
talked after that I felt like it was a
different login to what anyone else had
seen after all the controversy I knew
that with someone as sincere in his
genuine his eye I'm looking him in the
eye thought I wouldn't get the YouTube
[__] version of Logan I was gonna
get the real person and I respected and
appreciated the fact that he came
prepared to deliver that and let his
guard down and weirdly because we had
problems in the past we kind of bonded
over that experience and sort of let it
all go
after starting the podcast just because
I was inspired by Joe Rogan to make
something that got that much attention
that many listening to a message about
how serious suicide is was really
important to me when it comes to talking
to log in about fighting Jay Jay I
believed Logan a lot more than I ever
believed Joella like mentally I thought
no quit at all in him and I thought I
was looking at a man who was a big dude
I did believe Logan could lose the fight
but I didn't think you'd be finished I
thought Logan was getting to a decision
he is just so stubborn such a born
winner and a born athlete that there's
no way this kid is gonna quit no chance
when I supported JJ I believed his
confidence in having more skill than
Logan because it makes sense he's been
boxing longer Logan's gonna be at the
same point JJ was when he fought Joe
realistically but I just didn't believe
we'll have enough to finish Logan like
Logan is just such a big stubborn
[__] I know how much Logan
values being number one if he didn't
really believe he was gonna at least
look good in there he would never have
gotten in the ring and that was enough
to make me think even without the
footage of Logan the ego of the man is
not going to be that Bruce he's not
gonna leave himself wide open and
therefore he's gonna be competent and
with JJ I believed he had the boxing
skill advantage but I just couldn't see
him finish and Logan and I told everyone
around us this he's going to a decision
Friday August 24th way and winds are
awkward you know you're in a room that
isn't big full of the media security
guards you now got me on stage
introducing me on there you're then
stripping down your underwear before
looking dead in the eye of the guy who's
gonna be punching you in the face 24
hours later you mustn't be pleasant we
had a couple of vicious advice the
Nissan gave mr. J swing like they look
like they wanted to rip each other's
heads off there and they're scarce and
Rocco Rock I was a little bit more
awkward maybe we're gonna kiss each
other like it's weird the tension is
building throughout every set of
fighters who comes out until we get to
Jake versus Dan G Jake comes out looking
readied we're in a chain that's probably
more valuable than every penny I've
spent my entire life Deji on the other
hand comes out looking like a puddin
when he got on stage I was not
encouraged I was worried for him and
luckily I seen him hitting pads before
the fight which give me a lot more
confidence than what I had it weird
then Logan comes out and I'm sort of
reminded of a podcast I did with Dan
Hardy UFC fighter who told me about the
reptilian state of mind you get in where
it's about beating the other guy killin
winning is psychotic
you know and Logan came out Niram a
dummy of the Joker like he's enjoying
this like he loves this and the way he's
built like for whatever people might
think about him having a professional
fight one day the guys build like a
professional fighter six to long-limbed
muscular shredded he looks like he could
compete you do not see guys built like
Logan Paul in English schools you just
[__] don't
I've never seen anyone in my life built
like this guy JJ comes out similar
reptilian state of mind like he's
unemotional he's there purely to make
you emotional he's got a mask on of
Logan's girlfriend for Christ's sake
he's doing everything he can to the
bitter end to get in Logan's head into
the poor cat his eagle Logan laughs it
off at first but when they get nose to
nose and JJ is trying to talk directly
to Logan's girlfriend that it was
bubbling it was about a girl I'm on that
stage so many security guards so many
entourage coaches fighter like this this
thing's gonna collapse at any point now
we let lon with how heavy I am and I'm
just thinking dude just don't [__]
hit each other for God's sake I'll break
it off we've made it to fight day
without any for punches throwing thank
God the day of the fight I meet Joe
Walla he's on commentary with me this
time so I don't have to be shouting at
him while he's in the ring I I'm quite
relieved at that to be honest with you
and I know that me him and Lawrence will
have a good laugh doing commentary
Nicholas I was really relaxed at this
point no nerves I've got this I can do
this I think about all the thought it
and being like millions of people are
gonna watch this it's one of the biggest
combat sporting events of the year this
is your big chance to impress the UFC or
people like this and guess what
it's only a second time commentate and a
fight ever I would have [__] meself so I
tried to just reason it and be head of
I'm just watching me it's having a punch
off when I talk about it it's easier
that way the arena blew me mind like
there was people screaming at me for
pictures and
and autographs and then you it all
becomes sort of like real like [__] me
the off people actually sat at home
watching these videos there's not just a
number going around I really think this
is all happening around us and we've
gone from watching Joe and Theo in a gym
on a laptop while I talked it before and
comment it into 20,000 people are gonna
be watching in this arena while I'm
trying to interview the winner of this
fight once again I'm not taking it too
seriously
you know I'm chill it's like that moment
on Jurassic Park where the t-rex is I
just gets a little bit smaller like
that's what you feel the hair stand up
on the back of your neck and everyone's
like it's electric we sit down we chill
out hurry boar on the desk we're not
allowed alcohol this table to really
piss me off and just getting anything
like pizza became a nightmare but I just
thought I've got four and a half hours
to do my absolute best and let's just go
for it lads so the first fights coming
out it wasn't a great I'm not gonna lie
and it took a while to get going but
like there were some funny comedic
moments early on and you could tell each
win regardless meant so much to all of
the boys involved and you could not be
happy for them the tension just kept
building with every fight and when
you've got phase sensei predicting that
he's gonna win in the third round by a
liver shot and he shouts at me on
commentary I'm calling it now while he's
in the ring and then goes ahead and
doesn't like those moments were so
entertaining being a commentator is
providing the soundtrack to the epic
things people are saying on camera and I
was just trying to give those boys the
best soundtrack I could for the best
night of their lives when gibble and jay
came out if i like right well yeah now
we're on the final three fights and i
know that this is going to be a great
fight because gable is a nightmare he's
non-stop pressure and jay is one of the
toughest bastards you'll ever meet in
the entire life this is guaranteed
fireworks and it delivered there was
points where I just thought no way Jay
is done and then he just comes back with
some massive punches out of nowhere like
I still go on unbelievable and give or
just doesn't let you breathe like he is
a [__] nightmare and then to call out
Joe after he's just got done beating Jay
I was like
Jesus you're thirsty clicks but then jaw
wouldn't back down straight in his face
screaming it's all and I'm like Joe will
never back down and I had to grab ahold
of them
and make sure that this didn't end up
starting right there and then outside
the ring so the music hits
Jimmy and I'm low-key like liking that
song on them speakers it sounded [__]
sick Jay comes out all why everything
looking like a character from Mortal
Kombat I don't know what the face masks
were necessary boss but yeah he looked
the part and he was acting the part
Deji certainly looked upon as well that
Rob was sick but he wasn't acting as
confident he sort of seemed sort of
subdued and I know I started the timer
and I was kind of worried I was like
you're about going to fight me at like
you know start looking like it but when
that bell went or he was in that fight
and he was throwing serious punches and
despite Jake getting the better of the
fight I think dead she surprised
everyone especially me there was a few
times where I thought Jake was gonna end
up and the dead she just came back and
dug deep and made everyone proud and I
was really happy for him when the tower
got thrown in I thought it was the right
call because he wasn't gonna win that
fight at that point and he'd already
proven anything he was trying to prove
in there Jake got that moment he's on
the ropes he's screaming the crowd who
didn't like Jake got the a moment of
saying I'm bleedin apart from desi but
he that guy never quit he was still
ready to go and like he didn't really
lose in anyone's eyes that day he went
from comedyshortsgamer KS eyes little
brother to just daddy so I guess in the
ring they interview the boys and that
was the first time I'd been in the ring
all night and it just it was intense
really intense but I felt like Jake gave
me some good answers before he started
plugging his clothing right literally I
was like what the [__] like this guy is
a marketing machine like even after he's
just been in a fight he's thinking
website go to shop slash like I'm like
you joking me right
like most youtubers forget to do that in
their videos he's just been hit in the
face and that's what he's coming out
with it probably rubbed people up the
wrong way at home because they're
wanting an emotional release from Jake
which he kind of gave but still the
marketing man prevails and that just
shows what kind of guy is you either
love that are you here I kind of respect
it I wouldn't have done it myself I then
going interviewed edgy after first hour
not seeing him which was a bit awkward
but I wanted him to know he was so
valued at that because it's when you
lose I guess you'd probably feel like
your lowest point but I wanted to really
build them up and let them know how
respected he was it remainders when I
spot the jaw when he lost a fight like I
felt sorry for Jo like you put all this
time and energy and effort in and you've
come away with an L like the least
you should get when you've fought hard
is a round of applause and to be built
back up and feel good and I just wanted
to give that to den G after leaving the
ring and watching that fight how good
Jake was got me thinking about how good
Logan could potentially be by this point
if that's going to be good enough given
what I've seen to be JJ like it was my
mind even though I only had like matter
of minutes to where like I'm still
thinking what's gonna happen like trying
to work it out because that is all we'd
seen we hadn't really seen much of Logan
we didn't know what the [__] was gonna
happen and that really helped build my
anticipation the lights go out Logan's
on his way to the ring the answers are
gonna come within minutes who is the
better man Logan's been saying I have
done enough to literally bury him I miss
my faith all the courts start ringing
enemy is what these two lads have said
to me in a matter of a week ago how
confident they are and like it's all
finally going to happen now and all the
while I'm trying to give the best
commentary I can to keep the audience at
home just as excited as I am in all my
past commentaries we've done the sideman
charity football matches Wembley cups
even the ksi well a fight we took the
piss we've had a laugh we've had a joke
you know it's better fun we didn't
really it's internet we were all made to
take the piss but this time we fell like
we had the eyes of the world on
and these boys were taking it so
seriously that we wanted to take it
seriously for them and do the best
possible job with what limited skills
that we have and make it a professional
sounding broadcaster they can look back
on and be happy with every single aspect
of it and not look at it in point the
finger at the commentary and say these
guys weren't up to the job and I wanted
to make sure that if they were landing
punches I was calling it correctly so
that ultimately if it did go a decision
people at home would feel like they knew
what had happened accurately as well I
care about YouTube and I care about how
YouTube comes across to the mainstream
and I just wanted to make sure that we
have a decent stand and unsure on every
level logon comes to the ring his
[__] dis trucks playing logins all
black everything looking like the ninja
from Mortal Kombat again I like the the
Maverick look at the shorts and gloves
and that the fact that he had like this
bird that I think initially started off
as his pet and now it's like here's the
emblem for everything and it's on his
black shorts and it looked like sick to
be fair he looked like the bad guy in
the movie and in this arena he was the
bad guy like and he said when everyone's
tweeting you you can't do anything about
it
when 20,000 people are booing them I can
do something about it that's gonna be
fine and the guy looked like he was
ready to do something about it he didn't
look scared
in the slightest jj's and his music hits
everything is on point I could feel that
booming through my chest like the
[__] bass in that arena I love that
song like the way it's almost demonic
like repeating over and over and over
again everything is on point like
telling Logan I am going to be perfect
when I'm in that
you are gonna be so [__] like it was a
hell of a song could be good idea and
the video set it off there ring presence
was different like Logan was stalking
the ring looking like he was itching to
get going
wanted a fight straightaway he'd been
waiting for JJ for a while I felt like
JJ's or deliberately did that and then
when JJ was in the ring he was so slowly
spaced on the ring with that mask on not
as not as anxious calm cool and when he
finally did take that mask off he gave
Logan like this six or a look and they
believed it like they were putting the
last drop of mental edge on each other
that they could get before finally
punching each other as the fight started
I expected JJ to be more bouncing around
in and out harder to hit you know circle
and Logan picking him off and Logan
having some success but I thought would
be a bit clear of who the better box I
was it [__] me up when Logan just
looked more comfortable in there and
looked so calm I thought you'd be a
little bit more on edge a little bit
more nervy after all the main games JJ
played with him I don't know if there's
any other youtuber who would have got in
there and done what Logan did like most
of them wouldn't want to run across the
ring and play right into JJ's harms
which is kind of what Joe did Logan
stood his ground pick the shot wisely
outboxed JJ used those physical
advantages and looked the part
there was an easy opening round from
Ashley and that really shocked me that
didn't not expecting the win the opening
round I didn't expect it to be [__]
easy I did predict JJ would have more
success as the rounds went on and that's
kind of how it went
another good second round for log and
even though JJ was trying other things
getting frustrated Logan just looked so
calm and composed what what kind of [__]
New York was like they were talking to
each other a lot and I wasn't I didn't
think they'd have the confidence to do
that because their skills are not going
to be advanced to where you should be
talking [__] mid-fight but they couldn't
help it there's such cocky bastards a
pair of them that they were top and that
[__] in it I just made saw entertain it
made it so good it felt after the second
round JJ realized I've got
[__] do something about this I can't
just let this current job me for the
rest of the fight I need move I need to
use what skills are being taught and he
certainly started to do that he was
shifting his way a lot more he was
moving his head more and trying to come
up login from different angles and it
worked and I don't think it was as
convincing a win in the third round but
he won the third round and that was so
important for him to build off of
confidence wise fourth round you were
seeing Logan getting tired he moving
that massive weight around isn't easy
and those arms punches weren't as
powerful he looked like he took the
fourth round off a little bit and was
just like I just need a sock windier and
make sure our [__] stay in this fight
because otherwise JJ could have really
poured it on at that point and the fight
could have gone differently
coming into the fifth round it felt like
Logan was about a gasps JJ was on the
ascendancy and even as great as Logan
had looked early on it felt like that
was gonna count for fuck-all JJ was
pouring on but Logan came out on that
fifth round with a second wind and he
started really strong throwing early on
giving judges something to worry about
so like JJ couldn't just curry on the
pace that he'd been setting and just
showing no fear I'm still here me I'm
still [__] here that round for me was
the one that turned this from a Jay Jay
win in to withdraw without that fight
back from Logan I feel like would have
gradually gotten worse for him he needed
that and he showed a lot of heart in
that fifth round to be fair to him that
six run was the most decisive round of
the fight and it was the final round and
it really put the stab down on who
finished the strongest JJ was all all
that log and Logan didn't land a real
punch of significance in that round his
punches had very little behind them he
was exhausted and credit to him he did
really well to hold on because JJ was
lighting him the [__] up
badal gets in the ring everyone knows
that that guy knows [__] box and he's
already had two people win that night
and he puts JJ on his shoulders as if he
believes you won the fight which
instantly gives a lift to every JJ I
found in there like well he mustered up
you know I mean he finished strong
middle Zach make you won the fight he
must have won the fight
but you can tell even on commentary I'm
still not convinced I'm saying this
could be a draw when I did get in the
ring
I noticed Michael buffer treble checking
the decision in his hand when I first
heard the decision was a draw so many
things went through my mind I felt for
JJ he finished that fight so strong that
he probably felt like at that point
while I was winning you know what I mean
I felt for Logan even because he'd
started the fight so strong and maybe if
he just being a bit fit I you know that
would have been his fight I felt for
myself a bit I mean it's only natural I
think about how this impacts you in that
situation and I'm like another one of
these fights after how good this has
been for my career is definitely not
nothing if they've got to do another
rematch
I mean I'm into it I've heard it's gonna
be in America I'm in LA in me mind on a
beach
[Applause]
yeah back into the ring the thing that
[__] me up the most at that moment was
having the gone interview JJ and seeing
the shock on JJ's face and he was so
confused
puzzled not with it at all and normally
at that moment when I got him he is full
of confidence talk the talk walk
[__] and I did not get that and
his looking like he's seen a ghost
attitude freaked me out and for the
first time in Gordon was how long on
camera I didn't know what a [__] safe
I got the first question no and we seem
to be getting somewhere and then after
that I was like this dude out he's
shocked and I'm I'm shocked because of
it I've got nothing what about me mind
went [__] blank people and then when
you when you don't know what to say the
spotlight that's shining down on you
gets brighter that the camera feels like
it's right in your [__] face JJ is
looking up at me like what the [__] do
you want to ask me the microphone just
seems to be glaring
we'll talk it was then [__] and I've got
nothing that was about two seconds it
felt like about 20 minutes that was my
worst moment on camera in my [__]
life all I could think I was a dunk your
family like that was literally the first
thing that come to me and thank God for
Deji coming over and giving JJ a hug
because that instantly was an awe moment
that just made most people forget that
[__] up I've just dropped in the middle
of the world when I went to Logan I
wanted to reference the past but also
give him credit for hanging on the way
he did at the end and ensure that you
know you can make a mistake and still
have hot and build him up do you know
what I mean but Logan was quite positive
it felt like JJ was more downbeat about
the result than Logan I think Logan knew
JJ was gonna be a real force and was
happy with how he did generally he
didn't lose it was his first ever fight
he'd never done that before and he can
take a lot of positives from Northerly
rounds and he he seemed to be feeling
better about everything JJ I felt felt a
little bit more sad because he didn't he
was talking about going pro before that
fight he was talking about embarrassing
Logan and while some people might think
he beat log and it didn't go down the
way Jay Jade really convinced himself it
was going to wear as I think Logan was a
little bit more accepting that he might
lose in his mind and it showed in that
post fight reaction how they'd set
themselves up for this I'm looking
around the ring and I'm in awe of what
happened like youtubers who are just
silly young Daffy lads making silly
videos have managed to put on a
pay-per-view that numbers the UFC would
be delighted with absolutely over the
moon with and these guys who weren't
taken seriously have got in there who
have turned up and went to war so proud
of them and and very grateful to them
for letting me be a part of it it just
makes you think if that young lad sat in
the living room with his grandma say is
now for the first time he'd probably be
speechless
[Music]
know what